Hey guys, how's it going it's Justine and today we're going to be chatting about my office because I've been getting a lot of questions
Since I've just posted a video, to hopefully
answer a lot of your questions about what gear do I use but then that video ended up spawning more questions about well what's your office
like? Where do you work? What do you edit with? So I thought I would make this video to give you guys a quick little
update on what I've got going on because I mentioned in a previous
vlog I had an organizer come in professional organizer like this is a thing like these people are
absolutely incredible. One of my downfalls is organization and I have very very poor
organizational skills like I'm not sure if it's just me but I feel like a lot of creative people we spend so much time
creating that the rest of our lives sometimes gets out of control now, not only is there
organization involved but there are some closet build-outs happening as well i have one master closet being built out so this is what this is
gonna look like
but this is what It looks like now
and if you guys can see all of these bins all of these things will eventually have a home.
Now all of these things in these bins came from places all around my house from my drawers from downstairs, from upstairs, from my bedroom
everything that essentially
didn't belong in the place that it was has now ended up in these bins and they'll soon will end up in this closet
that's not a closet yet. This little space right here will hopefully look like this
I'm so excited because the first few phases of This entire process is over and when I say It was insane like
Everything That i had in my house
Everywhere Was out in the open
Like It was Just so nuts. But anyway, this is my current office setup so I
kind of wanted to do a
Before and Then an after and also get some suggestions from you guys Because I'm having a very big dilemma but more on that
Later. Obviously The centerpiece of My office is right here, this is My
Lg Oled Wallpaper TV I did an unboxing and setup video of This previously so I'll put a link in the description and up here
In the little i if you guys want to check that out, but this thing is awesome it's one of those things when you're sitting
and watching it that it feels so realistic that It sort of almost confuses my mind like I forget that I am
looking at a television. The fact that it's so thin It actually
blew The minds of the guys That were installing It. They were like This is crazy we've never even installed One of these before and
They did an absolutely Incredible Job
So my phase two sort of for this TV setup is i really want to get this cable Behind the wall and That's something That
I'm gonna have to enlist a professional to do because Clearly i don't think i'm capable
Now this cable is Very
Important Because This Attaches to of the sound bar Here now the sound bar is not Just for sound this Powers the
entire screen so you plug everything Right Here into the back of the sound bar this is where the hdmi goes and right Now we
Have the New 4k
Apple Tv hooked Up Which i haven't even Got a Chance to try yet so you Guys Will be Witnessing my first time trying it
Out One of My favorite Things Other Than These Beyond incredible
picture quality of This television is that The Sound bar has dolby atmos so when i'm sitting and watching TV and i Turn up That
Volume It Feels Like You're in a Movie theater It Feels Like i Actually Have surround Sound set Up in this Room Which i don't
Using The Dolby Atmos it's Able to give you that Feel i wish that i could show you in this video What it's like but
I can't except for flailing My Arms Around because I'm getting so Excited
One of The Things that i was Excited about with This tv When i first got it was the future of the things that i
Could Use With it the first Thing has arrived is the Apple 4k TV now i'll be Able to take full
Advantage of The perfect color quality on this TV it's Kind of Crazy Because the lg oled Pixels can Switch off
completely What This means is black Is
Actually Black Pitch Black
So this is still a Part of The tv right Here
This is still a Part of TV and the reds are redder like The colors are so Incredibly Vivid like i Said before it's Kind
Of a surreal Experience
Bye-Bye
Oh my God
One of the Movies that i was Excited about That Was in 4k hdr
Spider-Man Haven't Seen It i've Heard Great Things so That'S gonna be the first movie that i watch
To watch We gotta shut all the lights off
Gosh Where's the remote UGH
Another Thing that i'm Excited to connect to this TV is the new Xbox That Will be coming out Later This year, taking full Advantage
Of 4k and hdr gaming is gonna be really awesome to test Out on here
As i mentioned gaming You might Be confused as to why there are two monitors sitting Up when i have this
Massive Huge Tv that It could also Be gaming on so we had these
Stations Set Up where we had three of us playing destiny at The same time Two People could Be Playing on these monitor stations Here?
And The Third Up here on the tv it definitely Got a Little Bit crazy and a Little Bit confusing because we're all Yelling and
Screaming and sitting on This Couch Very Very close This is Matty's little Bed right Here so these two stations we have?
Astro Headsets Hooked Up to them and those are Just Connected Directly to the controller These gaming stations definitely aren't a permanent Solution but
For The time being While i'm super into destiny
This is what we've Got set Up here and this light Right Here is definitely not something that i usually have but i felt like?
It was Kind of Dark Over Here in the corner so i needed to put a Little Bit of light on Myself
I love these light Panels They're small compacts and They're Really Easy to use
There's one also Behind my Desk Which is Kind of permanent back there i use that a lot When i'm Shooting sort of like The
iphone Rumor videos When i'm sitting at my Desk
This is Actually Matt's Little small hd screen i need to return it to him but i really like It because it's easy When i'm
Kind of Just on the go of Vlogging and i need to see what it looks like Because Sony Cameras do not have a Flip-out
Screen
Come on this Is a New Addition to the desk this is the new Mophie
Wireless Charger For The New iPhones This Is also a Nice Little Apple Watch Charger Which Doesn't really Look Very good i got to get
A New one extra lens and these are some of My favorite lego minifigures Benny steve Jobs and Myself Plus Over here the original iPhone
That i Just Remind Myself
Started From The Bottom Now we're here so this Here is my editing station and this is Hooked Up to my macbook pro
This is the Usb cu Edition with The touch bar and this
Setup Is not Very organized but It Works for me i have it sitting Here?
Underneath of My Desk There's two hard Drives Hiding Behind It Which i use for archiving footage back and  Up here to this Mac
Monitor Which i've Been using for a Very long time and i'm so looking Forward to the imac pro or
Potentially Apple Releasing a New monitor Because i would love to have something to connect to my Macbook?
Pro i used these Little Samsung Ssds and these are so great Because They're Very Very fast
Especially When i'm editing Off 4k footage these are the T 3s and this is one of the new T 5s that i Just Got
And i thought that i wouldn't be Able to tell a difference in speed but Actually i Kind of can- Is that Good?
There we Go it Turned some lights on so over here this is what i used to do vo This Is the razer Siren Mic
And i actually Really Really Like This because it Allows You to also monitor Your audio and It Usually
Sounds Pretty Good for everything That i need it for This Works Very well to make It sound like I'm actually in some sort of
A studio or something When Clearly I'm not hey what do we Got over here?
Gotta move This light Over Here so this will look Better
from The
Office so over Here this is where i have My?
Surface studio and You Guys probably are like Just scene Why do you observe a studio so this Surprisingly Replaced My
Gaming computer i wasn't Really Doing Much PC gaming and The PC gaming that i did do this Was Perfectly
fine for It It completely eliminated The tower don't Get me wrong i absolutely Loved having an Incredibly
Overclocked Powerful Pc That's Water Cold It Was Huge it's a Tower its massive i didn't Need it it Was super clunky and it Was
Basically
Overkill for anything That i was Doing Number two i'm not using it to its full potential so i plan on Actually putting that in
Another Place to have a completely separate gaming PC set Up for anybody who may come over who wants to play Pc Games or stream?
But for me right Now in my current state of me still editing my own videos i don't have time to do anything
Except shoot and Edit and When i do Play Games i'M Playing for my own enjoyment
Not to stream or post or Edit Any more gaming content Because i don't want to add Any more
to my plate a lot of These Days Maybe if i Get Somebody to edit Half My videos I'm Mostly even Playing Diablo 3
I know diablo 3 yes i've Been Playing again It Was One of My most favorite Games ever
Overwatch Actually Runs Really Well on here and of Course Minecraft
Also Over Here connected to the PC i've Got This our MC babyface audio interface Which is connected to this sure microphone this microphone is
Way Better Than the Saira that i have over there so depending upon the project or what i'm Doing it will sometimes switch These Microphones
Back and Forth or i'll Record The Audio Over Here take it to the mac and next to that This is my astro mix amp
Next to that is my super nes Classic Next to my nintendo switch That Is also Decked out in Classic nes
Decal Style It Looks so good i
Cannot Wait for Mario Odyssey
And Below That attendance Which we've Got the playstation 4 Pro and then Below That we've Got the xbox 1s
Which is connected to a monitor at the couch
Let'S Just completely Ignore my lack of cable Management
Please Which leads us back to the lg wallpaper TV and What this sound bar is on this is the dilemma that i'm not sure
What to do and i first started doing an office
Reorganization i thought hey maybe i'll Just Get Rid of these Desks Then i realized that I'm Very Attached to these desks and i absolutely
Love the look of them so then figure out
How to make This Work but the problem is this center console is Actually Just a Dresser from One of My Bedrooms and it Does
Not fit the sound bar at All so I'm looking for a Really Great media Station to put here so i have opened
Suggestions What do you Guys think i Should Do Should i mount the sound bar Should i not mount the sound bar i'm also Working
on something Else
That i will Hopefully Have installed Soon Which Will be a Very Very fun video that i cannot Wait for you guys to see i
Will also Probably Need Room for That
Too so that Thing Will Need Room and
That Thing is about the size of a PC tower Which IS also one of The reasons that i was Kind of trying to make
Room Over here getting Rid of One of The towers
AnyWay I Feel like Making This video is Kind of Crazy Because This has Been my dream office
Since i was i don't even know since i ever started first getting into tech Now i used to watch leo laporte and he still
Is one of My favorite People ever i used to watch leo back in the day
When i was Very Very Young me and my Grandmother Would Watch It all The time after School we'd Watch the
Screensavers and i would see all of Their Crazy Setups That They would have and all of The amazing tech That They were
Reviewing and i Was like Man One day That's What i want to do and it's pretty Crazy Thinking back to my childhood Self and
To be sort of Living Out that dream of What i wanted to do when i was little
It's crazy to think that the Jobs that we are Doing Now they never even Existed
When i was a Little Child Like The Jobs that you Guys are going to create that don't Exist now is going to be so
Fascinating Anyway That Could be a Whole nother tangent and a Whole nother topic
But What i am most Excited about is that i'm Able to share with you guys My
Excitement for Things Things that i love and you Guys share those Things back with me i'll see you guys in my next video and
I'll see you guys in the comments until then i'm gonna use this Christmas Chapstick and
Go out of This video
Could Be Flink Destiny Right Now but no i'm not